en 1960 la société française est
déchirée par la guerre d'Algérie et
Jean-Paul Sartre parce qu'il défend le
refus de prendre les armes contre le
peuple algérien focalise sur sa personne
une partie des tensions il sert de bouc
émissaire des manifestants hurlent le
carrément fusillés Sartre sur les
Champs-Élysées certains craignent que le
pouvoir ne finisse par le faire taire
mais le général de Gaulle tranche on
emprisonne pas Voltaire
[Musique]
en effet Sartre est un peu un nouveau
Voltaire pendant les 30 glorieuses il
est bien plus qu'un écrivain ou un
philosophe il est la star intellectuelle
occidentale de l'époque le symbole même
de l'intellectuel il a aussi une
influence politique exceptionnelle ces
prises de position pèsent dans le débat
politique francophone et même
international il est la voie du
progressisme c'est-à-dire de la remise
en cause de la tradition il est
d'ailleurs une des références de Mai 68
et comme Voltaire sartrer craint par le
pouvoir pour vous aider à comprendre
comment Sartre est devenu une légende
vivante j'ai tiré de cette biographie
d'Annie Cohen cela 10 anecdotes
révélatrice sur le destin de Sartre vous
allez voir que sa vie est fascinante
parce qu'il détestait les conventions
les trois dernières anecdotes que j'ai
choisies sont particulièrement
étonnantes
je ne sais pas si vous en êtes déjà
rendu compte mais sartrer minuscule il
est souvent surnommé le petit homme
quand on le voit debout à côté de
quelqu'un d'autre ça saute aux yeux en
effet il mesure 1m57 c'est exactement la
même taille que son père qui était mince
comme lui alors que la mère est grande
en fait Sartre est le portrait craché de
son père Jean-Baptiste Sartre déjà
physiquement comme je viens de le dire
il est petit et mince comme lui ensuite
ils sont tous les deux très intelligents
le père de Sartre était un élève
brillant il a été trois fois lauréat au
concours général qui distingue les
meilleurs lycéens de France il a eu deux
bacs différents ça se faisait à l'époque
un peu comme on peut cumuler les masters
aujourd'hui et enfin il a fait
Polytechnique Sartre ressemble aussi à
son père sur le plan psychologique comme
lui il a un tempérament de marginal son
père manifeste son esprit critique dans
l'armée française ils sont tous les deux
sensibles au sort des défavorisés et
enfin ils sont tous les deux très
ambitieux son père avait fait
Polytechnique parce que c'était vraiment
un ascenseur vers l’élite à la fin du
19e siècle Sartre est donc le portrait
craché de son père mais quand on lui
pose des questions sur la famille il
répond je n'ai pas eu de père c'est vrai
qu'il ne le connaît pas puisqu'il
n'avait qu'un an quand son père est mort
mais ça va plus loin en fait Sartre ne
parle jamais de son père et lorsque les
gens l'interrogent il fait comme si son
père n'avait pas existé une fois qu'il
sera une star il brouillera les pistes
des journalistes et des biographes Annie
Cohen solaa en donne une explication
psychanalytique c'est parce que Sartre
voulait garder sa mère qui était une
belle femme pour lui seul comme son père
travaillait dans la marine il était
rarement présent pendant les 15 premiers
mois de la vie de Sartre et lorsqu'il
est rentré pour cause de maladies Sartre
traduit partagé la tension de sa mère
avec son père et c'est là que serait né
son avion pour son géniteur
Sartre n'est pas un enfant qui respire
la santé il est souvent malade un jour
une mauvaise grippe lui laisse un
strabisme de l’œil droit vous en êtes
peut-être déjà rendu compte sur les
photos instrabisme c'est un véritable
handicap en terme d'apparence Sartre
dira toute sa vie qu'il est moche parce
qu'on le lui a sans cesse répéter déjà
qu'il est minuscule comme on peut s'y
attendre à l'école puis au collège il
est un véritable bouc émissaire les
garçons dont les pères sont à la guerre
se moquent de Sartre et le battre pour
s'en sortir il va développer sa
personnalité et son intelligence à
partir de l'adolescence il commence à se
prendre pour un génie et il invente des
histoires pour impressionner ses
camarades de classe mais au collège ça
ne marche pas donc il se réfugie dans
les livres et dans l'écriture il écrira
je déteste mon enfance et tout ce qui en
survit son charisme compensatoire
devient efficace à partir du lycée à
l'internat d'Henri IV non seulement il a
des résultats exceptionnels mais il
développe une personnalité que ses
camarades disent écrasantes il est
intellectuellement brillant il a un
humour méchant qui fait des ravages il
multiplie les blagues et les
provocations contre l'autorité la
légende dit qu'il aurait vomi sur les
pieds du proviseur d'Henri IV après le
bac cette anecdote montre que la
personnalité brillante de Sarthe est une
adaptation psychologique qui lui a
permis d'obtenir l'attention et l'amour
d'autrui malgré la version qui inspire
son apparence je vise un peu trop de
l'admiration que les autres ont pour moi
à vrai t-il bien plus tard
après ce n'est pas le strabisme qui
explique l'excellence scolaire du Sartre
adolescence à grande culture pour son
âge et son don pour les lettres non ça
il le doit à son grand-père ce
grand-père Charles Schweitzer est un
homme très cultivé et passionné par
l'éducation parce qu'il descend d'une
lignée d'instituteurs développer
l'esprit de son petit-fils c'est un peu
le dernier projet de sa vie donc il s'y
consacre à fond il écrit dans une lettre
rien n'est plus délicieux comme de
cultiver et dans ce Manset ces petites
intelligences il donne à Sartre un
entraînement individualisé d'élite les
grands écrivains l'histoire la
géographie et la musique classique et
comme ça entre n’intègrera l'école
publique qu'à partir de l'âge de 10 ans
son éducation jusqu'à cet âge consiste
exclusivement à recevoir les cours
particuliers de son grand-père et puis
il y a aussi la bibliothèque du
grand-père qui comprend plus de 1000
volumes et où Sartre passe beaucoup de
temps une fois qu'il sait lire bon vous
compreniez mieux pourquoi Sartre était
un enfant prodige c'est son grand-père
qui a créé le plus grand intellectuel du
20e siècle
y aurait-il eu Ronaldo sans Messi et
Messi sans Ronaldo peut-être pas parce
que l'émulation joue un rôle important
dans la performance et c'est pareil pour
la performance intellectuelle certains
penseurs trouvent leur motivation dans
la volonté d'égalée ou de surpasser
d'autres penseurs ils font des efforts
considérables de réflexion de lecture et
d'écriture parce que leur concurrents en
font également il existe un verbe
anglais qui exprime bien cette idée tout
out work l'émulation a également joué un
rôle important dans le dessin de Sartre
l’influence de son grand-père a été
déterminante mais ce n'est pas la seule
à l'internat d'Henri IV il se lit
d'amitié avec un autre génie
intellectuel Paul Nyan ils vont être
inséparables pendant 7 ans Raymond Aron
qui les rencontrera plus tard dira je ne
peux pas parler de Sartre sans parler de
nisant il se ressemblent même
physiquement au point qu'on les confond
parfois pollinisant c'est l'auteur du
fameux récit de voyage Haden Arabie dont
vous avez peut-être déjà entendu les
deux premières phrases j'avais 20 ans je
ne laisserai personne à dire que c'est
le plus bel âge de la vie comme ça il a
une énorme culture et il est un
boulimique de lecture mais en plus niant
écrit vite et beaucoup il a déjà publié
des textes dans des revues étudiantes
quand il fait la rencontre de Sartre au
lycée à Henri IV ils ont tous les deux
les meilleures notes et niant seconde
Sartre dans ses provocations en prépa
littéraire à Louis-le-Grand il travaille
énormément et il se voit comme des
surhommes de Nietzsche ils font de
longues marches dans Paris en discutant
il réussissent tous les deux le concours
de l'École normale supérieure ils y sont
admis avec un certain Raymond Aron du
lycée Condorcet
on dira souvent de Sartre qu'il est le
plus célèbre normalien du monde mais il
a d'abord été le plus célèbre étudiant
pendant sa scolarité à l'École normale
supérieure de la ruse d'Ulm il est une
véritable star sa personnalité a le même
effet qu'au lycée et en prépa son humour
féroce fait des ravages dès le début il
multiplie les canulars il ne peut pas
s'empêcher de provoquer l'autorité qu'il
s'agisse du directeur de l'école ou de
la hiérarchie militaire il impressionne
ses camarades qui sont pourtant déjà
très doués en lettres par sa puissance
de travail il y a toute vitesse 300
livres par an tout en multipliant les
soirées il a même un peu une réputation
d'alcoolique son ambition intellectuelle
est illimitée il lance un de ses amis je
veux être l'homme qui sait le plus de
choses et Sartre se distingue encore par
ses talents d'acteurs de chanteurs et de
pianistes il a notamment un don pour
l'improvisation enfin il pratique aussi
la box il a gymnastique ce qui lui donne
un physique musclé tous ces ingrédients
en font un personnage légendaire lorsque
Sartre entre dans une grande pièce
remplie d'élèves tout se remarque son
arrivée et prononce son nom
lorsque Paul Nyons dépressif quitte
l'école normale supérieure Sartre se
rapproche de Raymond Aron et là c'est un
duo tout à fait différent Sartre et
Aaron sont de Spar une partenaires
intellectuelle Aaron raconte que Sartre
n'arrêtait pas d'inventer des théories
puis qu'il venait lui en parler or
Raymond Aron c'est pas le genre à être
d'accord avec n'importe quoi non
seulement il est très cultivé et très
intelligent mais en plus il est
intellectuellement très prudent il
identifie facilement les failles d'un
raisonnement pour le dire plus
franchement mais là c'est mon avis
personnel Raymond Aron est un des rares
à être intellectuellement supérieur à
Sartre parfois dans leur discussion à
l'École normale supérieure lorsque
Sartre soumet une idée mais Caron
n'accroche pas Sartre se met en colère
le problème de Sartre comme le souligne
déjà ses profs à l'époque c'est qu'il
est imprécis et qu'il mise trop sur la
créativité de la pensée il est certes
brillant au point que son éloquence est
dissimule ses imprécisions 99% du temps
mais avec Aaron ça ne passe pas toute la
France pourra constater la supériorité
d'Aron lors d'un débat télé sur l'art
abstrait à la fin des Trent glorieuses
Sartre qui est toujours partisan de la
créativité défend l'art abstrait Aaron
le laisse s'exprimer puis il démontre
logiquement que l'art abstrait n'a pas
de sens son raisonnement est si clair et
si fluide que Sartre et sans voix c'est
évident Caron a gagné le débat mais un
journaliste dira le lendemain en
paraphrasant une vieille formule la
célèbre phrase il vaut mieux avoir tort
avec Sartre que raison avec Aaron on
utilisait encore cette formule de nos
jours pour dire qu'on a intérêt à se
ranger du côté de l'opinion dominante et
oui à l'époque du débat les idées de
gauche de Sartre sont dominantes dans
l'espace intellectuel français
tandiskaron un libéral et qui dénonce le
marxisme en le comparant à une religion
passe pour un infréquentable
une autre preuve de la supériorité
intellectuelle daron c'est qu'il finit
premier au concours de l'agrégation
alors que Sartre le rate dès l'écrit
pour se justifier il dit qu'il a trop
misé sur l'originalité il doit donc
repasser l'agrégation Aaron lui
recommande d'être plus scolaire et cette
fois-ci sartre-ci met à fond il prépare
le concours à la Bibliothèque nationale
et dans les amphithéâtres de la Sorbonne
il remarque une jeune fille qui est elle
aussi candidate elle semble très
sérieuse elle est jolie grande même si
ce n'est pas difficile d'être plus grand
que Sartre et elle a de beaux yeux bleus
elle intègre son groupe de travail et
alors elle est subjuguée par la
supériorité intellectuelle de Sartre
elle estime qu’il est un véritable génie
il va chapoter son développement
intellectuel il se voit et discute tout
le temps ou plutôt Simone de Beauvoir se
mesure intellectuellement à Sartre et
elle constate systématiquement qu'elle
ne fait pas le poids ce sont ses propres
mots ils échangent également des lettres
parfois quotidiennement au bout de trois
mois Simone de Beauvoir parle de Sartre
comme du double dont elle avait rêvé
quand elle avait 15 ans il réussissent
tous les deux lagrégation Sartre qui a
trois ans de plus que Simone de Beauvoir
a un meilleur classement mais le jury
lui reproche d'être approximatif leur
relation durera 51 ans
on connaît Sartre comme la star
intellectuelle des trentes glorieuses
mais il n'a pas atteint le succès
littéraire et la notoriété immédiatement
on oublie qu'il avait une vie avant en
particulier on oublie qu'il a été prof
de philo pendant 5 ans à 26 ans il est
envoyé dans un lycée du Havre et là
c'est très difficile pour lui parce
qu'il veut tout sauf une vie rangée et
encore moins dans une ville de province
mais il n'y vivra jamais comme un
provincial au contraire il contracte
certaines habitudes de marginales qu'il
gardera toute sa vie il vit dans un
hôtel pas terrible près de la gare il
mange dans les restaurants et il
travaille dans les cafés ce qui est
toutefois assez commun chez les
écrivains ce qui est encore plus
intéressant c'est qu'il fait court d'une
manière qui annonce l'idéologie
libertaire de Mai 68 et plus
généralement de la libéralisation des
rapports entre l'enseignant et les
élèves à partir de la fin des trentes
glorieuses dans le cours de philo de
Sartre il n'y a pas de code
vestimentaire et les élèves ont le droit
de fumer en classe le prof parle sans
aucune note il respecte les élèves
aucune hiérarchie explicite ne lui
permet de les dominer ce qui la
définition même de hiérarchie du coup
Sartre échange librement avec ses élèves
d'homme à homme ils les encourage à
réfléchir par eux-mêmes pour se faire
leur propre opinion mais ça va plus loin
Sartre sort en soirée avec ses élèves il
va au cinéma avec eux et ils les initie
même à la boxe il cherchait des sparines
partner la première année il fête le bac
avec ses élèves en se bourrant la gueule
dans une maison close et il est ivre le
lendemain à la remise des prix en fait
il est un peu comme un grand frère bien
sûr ça rend fou le proviseur il se rend
compte que la classe de Sartre devient
un bastion du gauchisme et puis surtout
que le prof ne respecte aucune
convention Sartre ne note pas les
absents il n'impose pas aux élèves
d'apprendre le cours il ne corrige pas
régulièrement des copies il ne met pas
de notes mais voilà ces élèves
obtiennent de super résultats au bac
certains fils d'ouvriers deviendront
même de brillants agrégés d'anglais
grâce à lui cette anecdote est
importante parce que c'est lors de ces
années lorsque Sartre est prof de philo
en Provence que né sa complicité avec
l'adolescence et cette complicité fera
de lui une des réf érences
intellectuelles de Mai 68
dans ma formation à l'écriture dans une
leçon je prends l'exemple du style de
Sartre pour illustrer comment il ne faut
pas écrire si vous lisez son essai
qu'est ce que la littérature par exemple
vous verrez que le propos n'est pas
clair en particulier les paragraphes
sont trop longs il met le confusément en
plusieurs idées et leur délimitation
sont arbitraire bref ça part dans tous
les sens si bien que le lecteur doit
vraiment faire un effort pour comprendre
pourquoi Sartre néglige-t-il la clarté
de son propos parce qu'il écrit trop
vite et pourquoi écrit-il trop vite
parce qu'il est drogué chaque matin il
se réveille après n'avoir dormi que
quelques heures et encore d'un sommeil
artificiel arraché par quatre ou cinq
somnifères avalées après un dîner trop
lourd il commence par un café mais qui
ne commence pas par un café puis c'est
le corydran à l'époque c'est la drogue
favorite des étudiants et des
intellectuels elle est vendue en
pharmacie en petit tube de 20 cachets
elle sera interdite en 1971 mais l'ange
d'aspirine est dans phéamine elle évite
la fièvre et calme les douleurs mais
surtout elle stimule le centre nerveux
d'une manière in elle améliore les
capacités intellectuelles tout en
apaisant l'esprit grâce aux corydran on
est à la fois talentueux et lucide une
fois qu'on a connu ce pouvoir on ne peut
plus s'en passer Sartre croque donc un
premier cachet après son café il se met
immédiatement au travail et en écrivant
il enfile un autre cachet puis deux
trois il ne compte pas il doit avancer à
la fin de la journée un tube parfois un
tube et demi à un ainsi disparu mais 30
parfois 40 feuilles sont apparues bref
c'est presque du 1 caché par feuille sur
la boîte en carton dans laquelle sont
rangés les petits tubes on peut lire 1 à
2 comprimés le matin et à midi puis
encadrer en rouge ne pas dépasser la
dose prescrite comment on travaille-t-on
sous en vitamine sous 15 à 30 fois trop
dans cet amine on écrit de manière
frénétique les mots coulent en flots
urgent les idées se juxtaposent comme
elles peuvent plutôt mal les cycles de
la drogue se traduisent par des crises
de surexcitation les accélérations de
lucidité et les excès de confiance et de
doute rythme le développement du propos
la prose d'un drogué ressemble à la
conversation d'un drogué ça part dans
tous les sens et on a du mal à
comprendre bien sûr Sartre paiera le
prix d'un tel dopage intellectuel en
juin 1971 il participe avec Raymond Aron
a une conférence de soutien aux réfugiés
du Vietnam et du Cambodge qui ont fui le
communisme et là tout le monde peut
constater le contraste physique entre
les deux anciens camarades de l'École
normale supérieure aaron est en pleine
santé tandis que Sartre est précocement
sénile
au début de l'année 1946 Sartre se rend
aux États-Unis pour donner une série de
conférences et là on se rend compte
qu'il est plus qu'une star
intellectuelle il est une véritable
légende vivante même les magazines de
mode parlent de lui on raconte que les
femmes se paient quand ils passent
devant elle lui le petit homme avec un
strabisme que s'est-il passé il s'est
passé que Sartre vient de lancer la mode
intellectuelle de l'époque son destin
bascule avec une conférence d'octobre
1945 il l'intintitule L'existentialisme
est un humanisme les organisateurs de la
conférence acceptent ce titre qui n'est
pas du tout vendeur puis il sent mort de
les doigts parce qu'ils ont beaucoup
investi en pub dans les grands journaux
notamment le monde Le Figaro et
libération mais contre toute attente la
conférence est un succès culturel sans
précédent bien que la salle soit pleine
à craquer et l'auditoire surexcitée
Sartre réussit un bon discours le
lendemain la presse souligne son courage
et donne ainsi naissance à la mode
intellectuelle de l'après-guerre les
mots existentialisme et Sartre sont
matraqués dans la presse en 1945 les
éditeurs à leur tour surf sur la vague
Sartre passe pour un nouveau Socrate et
la célèbre conférence a accouché d'un
petit livre de 100 pages tout aussi
célèbre qui se vend comme des petits
pains depuis maintenant près de 80 ans
cette anecdote montre que l'immense
succès intellectuel de Sartre
c'est-à-dire à l'incroyable diffusion de
ces idées et surtout une affaire de
contexte la presse désormais libérée de
la censure allemande fait de Sartre le
premier produit médiatique de
l'après-guerre et puis sur le fond le
discours de Sartre entre en résonance
avec le désir de liberté et de
jouissance que ressent la jeunesse
française après le traumatisme de la
guerre en réalité les gens ne
comprennent pas la théorie de Sartre ni
même le concept d'existentialisme qui
est technique assez rapidement
l'adjectif existentialiste échappe à
Sartre il devient synonyme de marginal
et branché l'existentialisme c'est à la
fois un courant philosophique et un
style de vie qui incarne la subersion
des valeurs traditionnelles nous devions
fournir à la prière une idéologie diras
Simone de Beauvoir
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu que vous avez découvert des
choses intéressantes et même inspirantes
sur Sartre si c'est le cas donnez un
pouce bleu la vidéo et puis laissez un
commentaire pour améliorer le
référencement de la vidéo ce n'est pas
grand chose et ça m'aide vraiment je
suis romain j'étais avec mon fidèle
Aristote et vous vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale rappelez-vous
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour vous intéresser aux
meilleurs de la pensée j'ai une question
à vous poser vous croyez vraiment que
les gens ont lu tous les livres dont il
parle bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand chose
et oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a 5 les étudiants et
les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez lu
Ronan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'il les applique les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet il brille par leur
culture dans les conversations et dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver dix fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit en cliquant sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez-moi
faites-le et vous me remercierez